I went into biomedical science because I  was in makeup school and my wrist was  like not working my right hand I went to  my rheumatologist and I was like I think  maybe I'm gonna need my wrist replaced  he goes joint Replacements are very rare  and so my wrist hurt like I couldn't  lean on my arm to bring myself out of a  chair and even just doing fine motor  movements so I wanted to biomedical  science and I thought I'd need to get a  PhD in microbiology or Immunology to  figure out my autoimmune disorder two  years into that degree I was researching  I figured out the rash that I had was a  Celiac disease rash called dermatitis  herpetiformis I started going down the  diet root paleo diet very restrictive  paleo diet just fixed me what are these  food allergies what's going on maybe I  don't need a PhD then